so today at PlayStation experience sony
unveiled a new uncharted standalone DLC
called The Lost Legacy and it's gonna be
starring Chloe as a main character but
the reveal for that was was a real bait
and switch like I had no idea what it
was gonna be yeah I totally looked like
Tomb Raider for especially because
Chloe's eyes kind of like Lara Croft's
Chloe Fraser being the thief accomplice
from uncharted two that's kind of
constantly double-crossing Drake and
everybody else involved but yeah and
then she runs into Nadine Ross she's in
this side looked like a middle eastern
kind of country maybe like Morocco which
I realize not Middle Eastern I'm kind of
adding on to the Middle Eastern maybe
somewhere in Africa I'm she's like
texting somebody saying I'm in and then
she got texting him up on the roof and
then she gets attacked but he's a few
guys in the Nadine Ross who was a
partners with a Eddie rake in on trade
for kind of just comes out of nowhere
and apparently they have a background
which I don't think they alluded to and
untried for so this could be a cool way
to flush out that relationship because
we haven't seen Chloe since uncharted 3
days and it's adding in some more
abilities that we didn't see in the
original uncharted more stealth it looks
like it and the ability to pick locks
yeah so that's like kind of adding on
not just like you know like story and
whatnot but new mechanics which you know
like for someone like myself is played
on trend for toys you kind of a muscle
memory now it looks like you'll be
learning new things didn't look super
in-depth a lock-picking maybe more so
than like i'ma thug the game like
fallout or Skyrim but maybe not as bad I
don't know a lock picking simulator so
Mike you were a big fan of uncharted 4
you gave uncharted for a 10 in your
review what do you want to see in this
DLC what'll make you come back and make
you feel like well this lives up to
uncharted 4 I would really like to see
kind of I don't know I would like to see
Chloe's backstory and kind of how it led
her to the events of uncharted two like
her and Drake and that whole like gang
peeves with Sully have this like rich
backstory it's kind of alluded to a lot
I'd really like to see it flush down now
that they're bringing Nadine Austin does
it seems like they're both kind of
badasses they're like fighting these
soldiers again in this up you know this
talent they were kind of or this
building they were in like you know
infiltrating I would really like to
figure out again like
ow Khloe met Drake I'm hoping maybe
we'll remits Drake in the dlc but it's
even not I really can't wait to see
closer you have to have great for this
DLC like that has to be tied at
something
I would not be surprised if Drake was
alluded to but I actually like I don't
necessarily want to see him but I kind
of want to figure out what led Chloe to
that gang of thieves we all know and
love I guess so we don't know too much
more about what's going to be when this
is going to be coming out how much it's
going to cost but I expect it'll be
pretty early in 2017 that we get to play
a little bit more uncharted 4 and you'll
be able to read and watch more of it
here on gamespot com you're late I
thought you were professional no you
should relax live longer
Oh